ừ ừ
anh ạ
anh alo alo alo alo
Em
có nghe được rồi Đúng mà Để em tắt thử
trong bò né
Ừ để em xóa hết cái cái này đi à
anh
alo alo mọi người nghe thấy em ở trên
kênh hành hạ
Ừ ok ok à
ê
kê nghĩa tận hai cái chat à hơi chat ở
trên YouTube Vậy nha mình sẽ xem trên
kênh trên YouTube để chat nhé
nay mình sẽ có ghi âm lại này là các bạn
Nguyên tấm
em à có quay video lại ạ
Ừ ok thì hôm nay sẽ học buổi đầu tiên về
Excel cơ bản thì hôm nay mình sẽ nói qua
cái đầu tiên là gì đây
à à
thì mình sẽ nói lý do để Tại sao học cái
này và công cụ để học thế này
bộ
công cụ để học cái này cũng là những
khái niệm đầu tiên về cái này nó ra gì
chưa
thực tế là mình đi dạy Nhưng mà mình dễ
thực hành nhiều hơn mình cũng
300 theo kiểu là kiểu thì thuốc lý
thuyết nhiều quá nhanh có thể các bạn sẽ
thấy nó hơi khác tự dậy trên giường tí
nhé
bị chọn mà alo
khi bị vọng à nghe ổn hơn chưa
các thiết bị hỏng không ạ
anh
không biết mình có chịu nha
à à
cho anh nghe xem mic rồi anh bị Băng
khi
mua Messi mà ở vùng không dùng được cái
A
anh alo alo nghe hai tiếng á
vì sao thế Anh không hiểu từ tình
anh em em một cái để mà đóng
Em thích ta clip tốt không
bí
mật audio input ở một nick hay tắt cái
này
Alo alo còn còn bị hai tiếng thôi
anh alo do OK OK
Ừ nó nó chơi cả hai đầu ở Bảo sao
đấy thì hôm nay là mình sẽ dạy qua về
mục lục và như thế này được chưa mà mình
sẽ ghi lại ở đây là mình đang dậy thì
đâu để mà các bạn Bạn nào là vào xem chợ
thì sẽ biết nhé ạ
à à
Ừ ok
Ờ thì đầu tiên là các bạn học online thì
các bạn có thể một là cài
khi cài những thế công cụ có sẵn ở trên
máy này mà các bạn dùng thường xuyên hòa
các bạn Thể tra ví dụ là mình mình có
cha để free online này thì nó sẽ ra cái
trang trang này nhé app will on Life
online rồi các bạn
nghe tiếng nhỏ alo alo tiếng to hơn chị
ạ alo alo
ở đại đơ mình cứ để mắt Balloon rồi Các
bạn có gì tự chỉnh lại tiếng mẹ ạ
ở đây
đây đây
anh
alo alo
Ê mày to hơn chưa
i-tác Alo thế đủ to chưa
anh alo alo
Bỏ kẹp tai nghe rõ đây mình sẽ tắt
thông cảm buổi đầu tiên em phải trình
chị cái thôi
Ừ thế đùi to chưa
Ừ ok rồi To thế To thế không chỉ mẹ lại
thôi
thì
các bạn là và mình sẽ dạy các bạn
bằng
spo à
khi Microsoft SQL thì nên là các bạn hãy
dùng cái này nhé bạn thể dùng cái này để
mà chạy có lệnh có thứ gì
Ừ ok thi đầu tiên là tại sao chúng ta
học cái này đã đúng không
chứ không phải là chúng ta học lập trình
chúng ta phải biết về cái này mà chúng
ta cần phải hiểu rõ bản chất một cái này
nó là gì đã Tại sao chúng ta cần học
đúng không
hihi cái khái niệm về Apple girl à các
bạn tra Google rất rõ rồi mình sẽ không
nói thêm sâu về cái đấy mà mình sẽ
cho mình mình sẽ nói về việc là các bạn
tiếp xúc với nó thường xuyên như nào mà
các bạn không hề biết bản chất Ở đây bây
giờ mình sẽ thử mở các bạn xem
là sự là các bạn lưu thông tin lại thì
sẽ có
thì mình sẽ mở thử excel của các bạn xem
nhé à
lịch sử các bạn bây giờ làm quản lý sinh
viên là sinh viên của một trường đại học
Trần Hạ các bạn sẽ sẽ lưu toàn bộ thông
tin của sinh viên lại
Ừ thì nó sẽ là kiểu như là
Long này
Việt Nam
1997 kiểu như ai hả Thôi 24 tuổi này
về Hà Nội chị ạ Thế à
đây
thì các bạn lưu lại thông tin lại vào
trong kiểu như thế này đúng không
Thì cái dữ liệu này cũng được tính là 1
là tao bây rồi đấy Nó kiểu thế
nhưng mà các bạn sẽ thấy là bây giờ mình
sẽ lưu lại dụng là à Văn B này 23 tuổi
này ạ
ở Cần Thơ trở lại thật sự ngay rồi bây
giờ mình muốn kiểm soát tất cả những cái
bạn nào mà đang ở độ tuổi 23 24 thì mình
tra rất là khó đúng không Mình sẽ tra
căn cho phép để tìm theo kiểu tuổi sẽ
rất là khó
thì mình sẽ thường mà mình sẽ tách nó ra
thành nhiều cột để quản lý thay vì kiểu
mình sẽ kiểu Rập khuôn kiểu ngay ở đây
Còn thiếu nó là nam chẳng hạn đúng không
đấy mà ghi nghe Đôi khi mình sẽ còn quên
mất thông tin và bạn ấy đang thiếu thông
tin gì nữa đúng không được như vừa rồi
bạn đấy thể thiếu giới tính là nó không
thì thay vì ở đây mình như này thì mình
sẽ ví dụ lại tên sinh viên này ạ
vì
sao giới tính sau đó tuổi này rồi đấy ví
dụ quê quán chè hạt đúng không Long này
Nam này tư này Hà Nội cho bạn
lại xong rồi Văn B này Tân An này 23 còn
hơi cả lại sửa như này thì các bạn sẽ dễ
dàng quản lý được thông tin của từng
người từng người đúng không Và sẽ kiểu
sẽ tra theo toàn bộ những bạn dụng là
thị c em ạ nữ này đã nhận 20 nữa ở
Đà Nẵng đi
kiểu như này các bạn sẽ hoàn toàn quản
lý được là bạn nào là Nam vào nữ các thứ
thử đúng chưa Thì cái này nó tí người ta
bây rồi đấy Và bây giờ mình sẽ học
esquare để mà quản lý cái này kiểm soát
Cái này như thế nào ạ
Mở mic rẻ alo
anh alo alo
thỉnh thoảng có vấn đề với mic còn tôi
không
à à
sữa mixxi đấy mua nước xịn đấy
ok ok Chắc là vừa rồi như có sóng điện
thoại ở cạnh mình nên nó bị dẹp ạ
à à
Ừ thế thì mình sẽ thử dạy các bạn đầu
tiên là mình sẽ dùng cái phần mềm mình
đã cài sẵn Cái này là ép ISO như này
đ.d cài cái này có dùng cái này nhé đi
à à
Ừ ok các bạn có gì Các bạn cứ chat nhá
vì mình có để đây đặt lọp chat các bạn
mà
Ừ nếu mà các bạn cài cái
apples server để mà để mà làm việc như
này thì đương nhiên là các bạn chỉ việc
nách thường em cài cái gì ở toàn
nicknack finish cho xong đấy
và cái trên cùng này thì các bạn sẽ điền
Nó kiểu như thế này nếu mà bạn nào chưa
biết chấm hoặc Glucose cũng được sẽ vào
được
lễ hội cam làm gì mình
xe mình nghĩa các bạn chỉ cần tập trung
vào màn hình thôi không cần nhìn cam đâu
ý
là các bạn sẽ ấn màn ukle này để mà tạo
một cái có lệnh gì gì đó
ở
đầu tiên là bây giờ giả sử mình sẽ tạo
một bàn là bạn sinh viên nào ạ để lưu
thông tin toàn bộ sinh viên kiểu ngại
đúng không Mình sẽ nhận xét thấy bộ như
thế này Nhưng mà thường là các bạn sẽ
làm được Kiểu là các bạn tạo ra thôi Bây
trước để mà lưu lại toàn bộ thông tin
với vào trong một cái ra tao bây
thì sẽ là crash tao bay này
dụng là quản lý sinh viên này
các bạn không nên ghi có dấu cũng không
nên có ruột cách ở trong này thường là
cái nó quanh chút thường là các bạn sẽ
nên ly nên ghi theo kiểu 22 triệu Nó
kiểu như này là ạ quản lý sinh viên là
mã sinh liên lạc và sử dụng như hai nhá
là Đây là kiểu lạ trong lập trình cái
khái niệm này là kiểu là snaki
tức là kiểu con rắn nó sẽ cậu có giàu
cũng dấu gạch dưới ấy ở dưới cách rang
khi chúng ta không viết tiếng Việt có
dấu hay là cũng như là không có vô cách
hay là kiểu như này kiểu này là kiểu
Kama được kamilkim kamilkim là kiểu con
mặt bà con sẽ là cấu trúc xuống mà lưng
nó cho lên đây hai kiểu viết thường
xuyên phổ biến của việc lập trình mình
sẽ nó qua làm tí và về sau mình sẽ nhắc
lại tàn các bạn chỉ nên tuân theo đúng
mỗi hai kiểu này và thì khỏa các bạn sẽ
gặp theo kiểu là còn thêm viết hoa chữ
cái đầu nữa
Em chưa
cho các bạn không nên ghi theo kẹo lúc
viết hoa lúc rồi không biết hoa và thực
tế là còn thêm cái nữa là các bạn đừng
có ghi nữa anh ở Việt
để tí nữa Ninh nước Việt thì không Không
ở được phân tích trong lập trình nó
không phải kiểu Mã Tư đình như thế này
và cũng không nên viết tắt hạn chế rất
hạn chế viết tắt đấy không có mã sinh
viên biểu ngay bởi vì đôi khi các bạn sẽ
không thể biết
lúc nào viết tắt nữa lúc nào không xin
lỗi
à À thỉnh thoảng mình sẽ xài thỉnh
thoảng Sai và lỗi chính tả nó hơi bất
đang dị hơn tí nhưng mà không sao cho
Google nó vẫn sẽ tự động sửa đó các bạn
lại thành Đúng rồi em Không sao đâu ạ
anh
không các bạn đừng cười kiểu gì Các bạn
sẽ gặp những cái trường hợp với thôi
Ừ ok đầu tiên các bạn tạo ra tao bay như
này đúng không Sao các bạn sẽ sử dụng nó
bằng cách này u như này đó và các bạn sẽ
thấy là để chạy mỗi cái gì đó mình sẽ
Bôi đen như thế này rồi mình sẽ cho anh
skill để chạy ngay đi
à à
em
có Pascal cốt là theo kiểu viết hoa tất
cả sự khởi đầu nhưng mà cái đấy đã thực
sự không phổ biến ở bên trong lập trình
lắm tức nhờ với tù từ ngôn ngữ nữa Nhưng
mình sẽ đã nói về những cái nó Việt nhất
dụng là theo kiểu là viết à
snaki Có camille kok giống như vừa rồi à
à à
Ừ đợi tiếp theo là mình sẽ tạo bảng đúng
không bạn sinh viên nhà em ạ Tại mình có
thể viết theo cậu gạch dưới hoặc giả
viết theo kiểu viết hoa chực
chữ cái sau đúng không ạ
ở đây thì đầu tiên là bây giờ mình sẽ có
tạo ra
thì sẽ được bây giờ để mà mình lưu lại
toàn bộ thông tin của kẻ bảng này đúng
không thì các bạn sẽ thấy ở đây nó bạn
chắc là có bốn cục đấy Không Tên sinh
viên giới tính tuổi mà quê quán chưa
mình sẽ Đây là tên sinh viên
tuổi này
giới tính này
rồi tí nữa đúng không và quê quán ở
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ thấy ở đây là nó đang
bảo đỏ nó bảo là thiếu kiểu dữ liệu của
cục này kiểu dữ liệu nó là gì đây các
bạn sẽ ở trong axwell các bạn sẽ còn
thêm khái niệm được kiểu dữ liệu đã Để
mình mở cho bạn xem
các bạn sẽ biết kiểu dữ liệu có khái
niệm cái intro này flash này triệu tra
phải cha mày đấy
và kiểu kiểu tách nữa
thì mình sẽ nói qua và những cái này
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
cái kiểu đầu tiên là kiểu inter là kiểu
số nguyên số nguyên nhá
sống yên và
một số Nghiên thì chắc các bạn biết nó
là gì đó Nó kiểu 12 xong rồi 3 4 5 6 rồi
đúng không
Hà Đông kiếm Bun đã yên tâm thăm tính
mình sẽ nói hết tất cả bạn
lần lượt lần lượt
số thực số thực thì nó sẽ bao gồm cả số
thập phân ngành các giới đúng không và
tra lại
[âm nhạc]
tra thì nó là nó là chuỗi thì sao nó
chuỗi sẽ là kiểu nó sẽ là kiểu giặt là
ABC như này ạ hoa cà ví dụ là sự lo lắng
nghe để ạ đứng như là các bạn có thể
viết theo kiểu là một nháy này nó vẫn sẽ
chấp nhận là sự đời tuần như cả
và đương nhiên à
em có dấu được có kí tự đặc biệt trong
ngày được có cả chữ có dấu cách toàn
thoải mái trong này được chưa ạ
Ừ
thế thì cái vai cha nó khác kệ cha điểm
gì hối trước mẹ từng hỏi sinh viên của
mình là sinh viên mình thì đỡ và trai
làng khiêng được kí tự đặc biệt ra sai
hai cái này để thêm được kí tự đặc biệt
Thế bây giờ mình giả sự mình cứ nói qua
trước rồi phải cái sự khác nhau của hai
hàng ngày đã nhá là xử với mình có 10
này và mình sẽ 10 đầy như thế này Đầu
tiên thì khi mà khai báo kiểu dữ liệu
cha và cha các bạn sẽ đều phải
có phải có cái khai báo lần sau nữa là
tối đa à
Ấn Độ ở Trung á bộ nhớ để mà chứa các ký
tự đấy nghĩa là độ dài tối đa của ký tự
đấy là bao nhiêu
ờ ờ
chế độ dài tối đa ký tự này giờ sự nó là
tối đa là 10 thứ tự đúng không ạ
ý thì cái sự khác biệt của hai thằng này
nó chỉ đơn giản có bài toán như này đây
mình sẽ thử hỏi các bạn chọn nhiều bạn
để biết có trả lời rồi mà sợ là là sự
nhé à Bạn đặt ạ bàn ở một nhà hàng đi
rồi Bạn đặt chỗ cho 10 người đúng không
phải báo là mười mà đúng không
Thì lúc sau chỉ có sáu bạn đến
hỏi
với kiểu nào
thì lấy đi bốn cái ghế
có lại chỉ để lại
đủ số ghế ngồi á
ở
đây thì các bạn rõ ràng mình nói vừa nãy
ý là mười mà để khai báo máy tính làm
tôi sẽ để bốn đủ 10 cái ghế đúng không
để cho máy tính lưu lại đủ mưa cũng chưa
Nhưng sẽ có một thằng là nếu mà bạn Nhập
vào 6 ký tự nó sẽ lấy đi bốn cái bộ nhớ
đấy thì theo các bạn nó thằng ạ
Ừ đúng rồi còn rất nhiều bạn học rồi thì
các bạn sẽ trả lời được nó đang Vespa
đúng không Đấy các bài toán dạng thôi đó
là ba cha nó sẽ tính toán lại và sẽ giúp
bớt xuống bớt đi để mạng máy tính đỡ tốn
bộ nhớ ngủ trưa
thì nhưng mà Nghệ Ok các bạn hiểu là pha
ta
sẽ
đầy đi Buồn ghê đúng không Nhưng mà cái
này nhược điểm cái này Thế thì các bạn
sẽ thấy Ok cái này đỡ tốn bộ nhớ rất
nhiều khi giữa cuộc thì mình sinh ra cái
tra là điểm gì đúng không ạ
Ừ Thì bài toán ở đây về toán đánh đổi
khi mà các bạn học tập trình từ khi nó
sẽ bài toán đánh đổi đó là cái này nó
tiết kiệm bộ nhớ nhưng nó phải mất công
xử lý thêm một đoạn đó là ok Cái này lại
đi muộn người rất là có thằng bồi bàn Nó
sẽ phải mất công thêm một lần nữa đếm
lại xem là bạn dùng bao nhiêu ghế và
thằng bồi bàn đấy Nó sẽ phải chạy đi lấy
bị mụn lấy lại bốn ghế đúng không Và Giả
sử Nếu như mà
số tự nhiên có thêm một thằng bạn thì
các bạn đến nữa thằng đấy lại mất công
bê lại cái ghế ra cho
em à cho thằng kia đúng không Đấy Nghĩa
thằng sẽ còn một thằng bồi bàn chỉ chực
để mà đi lấy ghế cho các bạn thôi đúng
không ạ
Thế thì thằng cha nó sẽ có lợi hơn rất
nhiều nó cố định giờ các bạn đủ số ghế
và nó sẽ không tội nên chàng bồi bàn nào
để làm việc đấy nữa đúng không dọn mình
Dung bởi vì mình đang ngồi điều hòa Đợt
mình các bạn đợi mình một phút thôi mặc
thêm về học đi
à à
Ừ cái gì đây mỗi như thế này
anh làm em cứ hồi phục hay bị rút đi
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ Ừ
mình cũng nhận là mình đi dạy rồi Mình
cũng từng đứng ở trước hắn hắn trường
của trường để mà phát biểu rồi nhưng mà
mình vẫn run vẫn run như ngày đầu vậy
các bạn thông cảm
nhưng sao mình không tim mình rung như
mình sẽ không có chuyện dung mà nói sai
đâu
Ờ Ok nếu nếu như vừa rồi Các bạn thấy là
cái vasa và bay xa cha này các bạn biết
rồi Tí giờ trong tên của sinh viên đúng
không
À thì mình sẽ cậu sẽ dùng cái gì thì
trường là mình sẽ dùng ra Trai Thì ra là
thế bởi vì tên của một người nó sẽ không
cố định và thường ai mình sẽ thường ngày
cho 50 ký tự nghĩa tối đa tên của một
người sẽ 50 ký tự
xe mình nghĩa là thế này hoàn toàn phù
hợp cho tên của một người thường tên
không đến nỗi dài dài lắm
Ờ tiếp theo Đến tuổi tuổi thường là như
vừa nãy mình nói tuổi có thể có hai kiểu
lại inter đúng không và flash theo Vừa
nãy có bạn nhắc mình là có xem tắc bồ và
Bun nhưng mà nó bồ bản chất nó cũng ở
flash chẳng qua nó là độ dài nó lớn hơn
thôi nên mình sẽ không đề cập ở đây con
Bun này tí mình sẽ giải thích các bạn về
cái bu này
đương nhiên tuổi thì có bạn trả lời đúng
không
Ừ Nó là kiểu đi ngủ ngon đúng rồi có bạn
nhắc mình nó vasa mình có nhớ nhưng mà
yên tâm để phí mình giải thích cái đầu
với Sa có bạn nhắc mình yên tâm các bạn
thì chất thằn lằn có nhiều bạn ở đây
biết rồi
chỉ có thể là kiểu các bạn thậm chí giỏi
mình có yêu mình không nói việc các bạn
vào APEC mình chỉ đang góp ý thôi Thôi
để cho sợ mình quen đấy nhưng mà mình
mình có lý do nó tại sao mình không nhắc
đến
Nên là các bạn cứ bình tĩnh đợi thì đã à
Ông Đồ ngồi trong fpso pro nó có bạn Bun
mà nó bit cứ bình tĩnh bình tĩnh nào ạ
ờ ờ tiếp theo về giới tính giới tính thì
các bạn lưu và nam và nữ đúng không nam
và nữ chẳng thường các bạn sẽ mình mình
lo không nói về cái việc là lưu lại thêm
giới tính thứ ba rồi đây Mình thường hay
nói chỉ để lưu về hai giới tính thôi thì
sẽ là kiểu nó sẽ ra Kiểu
kiểu thường ai kiểu là trà như này xong
rồi 3 ký tự cho nào
đấy thì mình sẽ tra 3 ký tự một vì sao
vì thường Thằng này nó làm 2 hoặc 3 ký
tự nó không chênh lệch lắm Mình không
cần phải thêm vasa để làm suốt nhằm thứ
tự đi làm gì đấy nó sẽ như thế
tiếp theo là về quê quán ở quê quán thì
à Thôi mình bỏ quê quán đi mình cho số
điện thoại đi đây có nhiều bạn sẽ mắc
Cái lỗi này
theo các bạn số điện thoại thì có bạn sẽ
lưu kiểu gì im flash này kiểu ạ Ba cha
này hay kiểm tra này Thế các bạn sẽ lưu
lại kiểu là gì ạ
từ Teka
teki
Ok có tách I
à à
ạ trà buổi tất cả các bạn học bài trước
vậy Tại sao tất cả được gõ vào nó số mà
tại sao mình không lưu là số mà mình lưu
lại cha Gọi cho cha
Ừ
Ok Mấy bạn kia chắc là biết biết trước
kết cái quá rồi đúng không rõ ràng là số
điện thoại đúng không Nhưng bản chất là
mình sẽ phải lưu số không phải làm đầu
và nếu mà mình đưa số cho thằng sẽ mất
số không đúng không là thậm chí thậm chí
có nhiều nơi nó sẽ lưu cả mã mã vào dụng
nữa cộng tám tư cả hai cái gì dưới rằng
đâu nữa đúng không Thế nên là mình chắc
chắn là mình sẽ lưu lại là kiểu cha cũng
và cha gì chúng không Mà như nhiều bạn
đang trả lời nó sẽ là tra
Tại sao bởi vì à
số điện thoại nó cũng thường hay cố định
về cái độ dài nên là mình không cần được
cha cha thay đổi và tra phù hợp với
những cảnh nó thường xuyên thay đổi độ
dài đúng không Thế nên là sẽ là xa
lúc nào chả sửa mình có thể tra 15 ký tự
chọn sẽ khá phù hợp vì
đương nhiên là số điện thoại mình không
đến nổi mì hay 13 nhưng mình tao nói
thêm và trường hợp mà cộng
A8 42 + về di dời nữa đúng không
Này thì nó sẽ phù hợp hơn
ở đó ok rồi Ngon
ở đại thịt thế này là cơ bản rồi đúng
không Mình sẽ chạy thử nha Đây mình chạy
thử Ok rồi Cũng chưa
ai Bây giờ mình sẽ thử Insert
in shop khái niệm đi suốt là sẽ thêm
sinh viên vào trong cái bảng này sẽ
Insert into này
sinh viên này thì sẽ truyền đủ toàn bộ
tên các cột này người tính này và số
điện thoại này
một đây Đây là kiểu Asus Theo các bạn ý
sẽ đầy đủ đấy là các bạn sẽ ghi đầy đủ
lại tên nữa cả cột tím mình sẽ thử kiểu
kiểu khác à
khi bé mình sẽ ghi ở Long này
23 tuổi này tỉnh Hà Nam lại chẳng hạn và
số điện thoại là
012345678 này
hãy kêu kiểu như thế này đúng không có
bạn sẽ thấy cảnh báo lỗi luôn ở đây đúng
không
ở cảng Cái báo lỗi ở đây và bìa sao bởi
vì là cái tên này nó là chuỗi Nên là các
bạn sẽ phải để chồng tôi nháy
giờ đây mình sẽ ghi tên có dấu thì đi
đúng không Thật sự anh Tuấn đi thì Tuấn
20 tuổi thôi
ờ ờ ờ
đã
và sẽ làm kiểu kiểu như này để mình sẽ
thử Insert vào đi
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ thấy là ổn rồi đúng
không Ok mình sẽ thử snacks xe Ford sinh
viên nào ạ Cái select from sinh viên này
tức là sao sẽ sẽ hiển thị lại toàn bộ
thông tin của các bạn hãy giúp được chưa
đó sẽ chạy thử này đấy thì các bạn sẽ
gửi có lỗi ở đây đó là tên có dấu nó sẽ
bị đánh dấu hỏi chấm đúng không ạ
ở đảo tập trung vấn đề các bạn lại nhảy
sang cái vấn đề khác rồi à
Ừ đấy thi Đấy lý do vừa nãy có bạn nhắc
mình đúng là tên đấy Thì mình sẽ phải
thêm một khái niệm nữa ở trong SQL
Server này có thì thế rồi còn cái tao
bài khác thì không cần đó các bạn sẽ
được thêm chữ N lần trước như thế này để
mà lưu lại nó theo dạng Unicode còn
không như vừa nãy bạn kia nói thì nó sẽ
giữ lại các IC thì nó sẽ lưu được có dấu
bị chưa ạ
ở đấy không phải liên quan đến ba cha2n
vua cha là nó có a và hai cha nó sẽ được
có dấu đâu phải nấu cá tra được chưa cho
mình sẽ lại dốc nó đi để mà mình tạo lại
cái bảng này một lốc đi hay các bạn sẽ
sửa lại bạn nhưng mà mình thể mình sẽ
không dậy
kiểu nhiều kính thức Yên Thế cho mình
cái chị dạy các bạn thiệu cậu cư rốt vào
đi Xong rồi tạm lại
như dốc đi nha mình dốt là sẽ xóa hết
lại đi nè
Ừ đúng rồi giới tính nó sẽ Nova tra nữa
đúng không
anh hả
a cho mình sẽ chạy lại thử này ok Ừ đấy
nó tuya mình mình chạy lại thử này các
bạn vẫn thấy lỗi bởi vì sao Bởi vì cái
này tươi nó vẫn hiểu là mình nhập được
Có dấu hỏi như mình phải thêm cái nơ là
trước thế này đều biết hoa vậy chị thì
mới hiểu là à Chỗ này nó có để nhập có
dấu thì chưa mình sẽ thể chạy lại Món nợ
này này để các bạn xem này
anh có Ok Ok đúng không
em có bạn đang bảo là giới tính thì nó
là nữ thế nên là phải là
và cũng nhờ n tra đúng không Nhưng mà ở
đây mình lại tiếp tục nói tiếp về vấn đề
ok các bạn hãy giới tính thứ ca nó đang
có chị có 0,1 và lặp đi lặp lại trực nam
với nữ thời gian mà vẫn là nặn nó rất là
nặng thế nên là mình sẽ chuyển qua dùng
cái gì
thì ạ Vừa nãy có bạn đề cập rồi đó là
khái niệm về beat beat ở nó sẽ lưu lại
không gửi muộn thôi
Ừ thì nó sẽ nhẹ hơn rất nhiều
chị thay gì Mình sẽ lưu lại cả chữ đầy
đủ là nam và nữ như này hoặc thận chữ
viết hoa nữa đây mình mình không nói về
giới tính thứ ba đã thịt Thế nên chỉ ra
nam mấy nữ rồi nhá
mình tạm quy ước 001 là một là nam không
là nữ một mình nhiều nơi sẽ quy ước và
như thế thì trưa
không vậy á không phải là trọng nam
khinh nữ đâu nhưng mà nhiều nơi sẽ quy
ước như vậy
thì mình sẽ lại phải lúc nó đi và tạo
lại nó theo dạng kiểu bit ngay nhé
hôm nay mình tạo lại à
hôm nay mình sẽ đổi nó lại thành kiểu
một như này thì chả
khi họ chạy lại này
đó Ok dự tính sẽ kiểu như một như thế
này đây chưa
đấy thì đây toàn bộ khái niệm nãy giờ 30
phút thôi công nhận cũng nhanh phết Đấy
bình thường mình sẽ dậy Cái này kéo dài
động lực tiếng đồng hồ cơ Để để nó qua
Ừ đúng rồi Mình mình không dùng Monster
nhưng mình nói là mình đang cố dậy các
bạn về khái niệm cơ bản trước đã cài
enter hay là cái nói chung là cháu liên
quan đến đây đây lời mình sẽ không trúng
sâu mà mình sẽ chỉ dạy qua các bạn về
đêm ml thôi à
khi bôi đen trước khi chạy Bưởi đây có
bạn hỏi rất hay bởi vì là nếu mà chạy
như này nó sẽ đồng nghĩa với chạy tất cả
lại từ đầu đến cuối tất cả cái trong này
thế nên là phải bôi đen từng cái chạy
Từng dòng một trạm đấy thì các bạn thiệt
bạn thế là một trong những cái bạn có
phải tinh ý đấy đúng không
bởi đồ vì đôi khi mình làm cái gì đó thì
các bạn nên để chị tại sao mình làm thì
đúng không ạ
em có dậy trương cơ à đấy thì
thì mình sẽ dạy những cái gì không chớp
mình để lên ngồi nhưng mà có có thể các
bạn sẽ không ý mình để link một cái đây
là lên askmen
bit.ly lên SQL và bây là Linh mình tự
mình tổng hợp nên có thể là sẽ có nhiều
bạn sẽ thấy là nó có thể không đầy đủ
hay cái gì đấy các bạn thể góp ý mình để
toàn bộ những kiến thức mình tổng hợp từ
ashwell cơ bản cho đến về sau mình sẽ
dạy cho các bạn nó thể trưng sau đến mức
độ nào thì có bạn ở đây nói về chịu girl
này các thứ thứ này Và thậm chí mình có
câu hỏi thi vấn đáp ở đây Cái này à là
mình tự làm cho cỏ sinh viên của mình
mình từng đi dạy rồi mà Thì mình làm nó
cả sinh viên của mình rồi Cái này câu
hỏi và đáp mình vẫn đáp cho sinh viên
thế nên là các bạn nó Hưng thú nhồi tìm
hiểu toàn bộ tất cả đống ở trong này môi
trả lời hết cái đầu ngay chữa cũng được
à mà yên tâm là Tí nữa mình sẽ đăng mình
đang lại cốt này để cho các bạn tham
khảo này mang lại video này và có cả có
phải bài tập nữa nhé câu hỏi bài tập để
mà các bạn làm trắc nghiệm luôn để mà
các bạn sẽ
sẽ cậu
làm bồi tự mình cảm nhận lại được Hôm
nay mình đã học những gì đúng không ạ
a
public to the web
Ừ ok
Ừ cái này lại thêm một linh mới hình như
nó vừa bảo Linh này các bạn vui sao truy
cập đi đốt nó có tải được Linh mới cho
xem thử cả
à À rồi nó không không truy cập trong
ngày được ở nó có tải vì à Cái liên quan
việc là bao nhiêu người đang like vào
cái này thôi các bạn
tạm không Vào đây cùng một lúc nhãn
không chết cái này đây mình mình mình sẽ
để linh linh này ra chỗ khác vậy mình
sửa lại link hay vậy
Ê thằng biết chúng đi không cho sự với
mình
anh em sẽ như thế sẽ dùng là để quảng
cáo luôn chứ tim.net đi mình sẽ dùng
linh của cet.net làm vậy
ừ ừ
à à
chứ ai
cô đơn ép keo nhé you tim chậm c.co đúng
không đó
ở lại mình sẽ tạo link này cho bạn
Anh kênh a b
ml2 DL là gì thì về sau mình sẽ nói hết
yên tâm cá mập mấy cái những cái mà các
bạn đang thắc mắc hiện tại có thể về sau
mình sẽ trả lời nhé
Có chứ Bây giờ nói qua lý thuyết mình sẽ
rất hạn chế nói vì lí thuyết
để mà Bởi vì mình hướng các bạn thực
hành mình hơi bị ngược một tí đã từng có
bài bài viết về cái đấy ở trên nhóm mình
rồi đó là học ở đại học thì nó sẽ học
cái kiến thức nền và rất nặng về lý
thuyết để các bạn có thể áp dụng thực
hành còn mình thì ngược lại mình sẽ dạy
các bạn đủ đến Mỹ để mà thực hành nhược
điểm là các bạn lý thuyết có thể không
vững Giống như mình thực là bị không
vững lắm nhưng các bạn biết thực hành và
từ thực hành các bạn sẽ có hương thú để
mà học và sẽ sẽ kiểu
chị sẽ học ổn hơn nhanh hơn đương nhiên
là về sau các bạn sẽ phải ôn lại kiến
thức nhé không thì các bạn không Vẫn
kiến thức đi không làm được chuyên sâu
về cái ngày này nhớ mình đang nói
Ừ
mình đang nói là để các bạn có kiểu có
cái nhìn nhanh nhất và tổng quan nhất về
cái ngày này để mời các bạn theo đã
anh đúng không ạ
à à Hiện tại thì mình không đi dạy nữa
Hiện tại mình đang làm ở công ty thôi
mình thôi ca chính vì mình đi dậy sớm
quá Mà mình kiến thức kinh nghiệm thực
tế mình ít thế nên là mình mình nghĩ là
tuổi trẻ này mình nên ra ngoài va chạm
đã bởi vì hồi đấy là mình học ở trường
xong thì mình được ở lại dậy luôn nên là
mình kiểu kinh nghiệm thực tế rất ít
Anh có bao nhiêu buổi dậy ạ từ bạn hỏi
con này cũng rất là hay bởi vì thực sự
đến bây giờ mình cũng không ước tính
được sẽ dạy bao nhiêu buổi nhưng mà mình
đã năng lịch cố định rồi nghĩa là một
tuần hai buổi thì mình nghĩ mình nghĩ là
thường là mình sẽ dạy ở trên trường nhé
Thì sẽ dạy Acquy là 15 buổi cơ bản và 15
buổi nâng cao em ở trên này thì có thể
sẽ sẽ nhanh hơn bởi vì trên này vẫn là
kiến thức nó kiểu tổng quát và các bạn
thể xem lại và các bạn không cần phải ôn
tập thì mấy các bạn sẽ sạch tự ôn tập ở
nhà để làm bài tập thôi Đây là có thể có
bạn sẽ nhanh hơn có thể tầm 20 Bụi kiểu
kiểu xe và một buổi như này thì cùng lắm
là mình sẽ rất hạn chế trên một tiếng để
làm phiền các bạn đúng không và cái này
thì ra cũng
à à
ờ ờ những người đã học qua rồi không ạ
à Cái hơi khó đấy thực ra mình còn anh
nghĩ việc là có thể nếu mà dư dạy thế
thì sẽ có một buổi cho những người đã à
Đã biết vì cái ngày này nếu mà Bởi vì
nhiều người cũng hỏi mình em biết được
một ít rồi nhưng mà bây giờ cần làm
chuyên sâu hơn một tí chồng ạ nhưng mà
có khi mình không đủ kiến thức chứ sau
lắm
Xin chào các bạn phải đội tầm mà
anh Chúc buổi nữa rồi Các bạn quay lại
thì các bạn sẽ thế kiến thức nó sẽ lên
đến chích girl rồi xong ngồi Chăm Sóc
Sơn là các thứ thứ
ý kiến thức của hôm nay thì mình định là
chỉ đến thế này đấy
Có bạn bảo Dậy tiếp à
Sợ quá thải các bạn Thôi thì kiến thức
hôm nay của mình Mình định chỉ đến như
này thôi Và bây giờ mình định là nó sẽ
sang phần hỏi đát hơn là kiểu
nói thêm vì nó nhiều rồi
300 các bạn đừng có lên Kiểu Học nhiều
quá trong một buổi học nhiều nghe hay nó
giống như bộ phim bom tấn đấy các bạn sẽ
xong 2 tiếng thì các bạn đọc lại rất là
ít thực tế mình đi dạy nhiều thì anh
mình biết mà thử nên là cũng không nên
học nhiều quá trong một bộ đâu kêu cả
dùng nghe hay nghe hay là một thứ mà
mình nó hơi bị nhược điểm được Hồi trước
thầy mình từng dậy vụ lấy đó là các bạn
đi học xong mà các bạn về mà các bạn
không đau não vì nó các bạn không đau
đầu vì nó chứng tỏ là ngày hôm đấy não
các bạn không động đậy với các bạn chưa
học hành được cái gì cả Thế nên là các
bạn ạ
à mà đang bảo là dễ tiếp thu các thứ
mình đang thấy nó thức ra hơi say say
bởi kiến thức hoàn toàn mới mà các bạn
phải cảm thấy khó hiểu về nó gì hơn
em yên tâm Hôm nay thứ bảy mà nó không
Thứ ba mình sẽ tiếp tục nhá và thứ ba
bây giờ được đương nhiên là mình sẽ là
mình sẽ đăng lại luôn video này và sẽ
đưa bài tập các bạn sớm thì sẽ cố Tổng
kết bài tập à Tầm 9 rưỡi là có thể là
mình kịp thì mà đăng bài tập cho các bạn
để các bạn làm luôn rồi nha xong rồi
mong các bạn vào làm rồi ạ
anh vào làm xong rồi chọn chị chia sẻ
điểm kết quả bởi vì mình sẽ có câu hỏi
trắc nghiệm mà họ sẽ vào được làm được
chia sẻ kết quả ở đây ngóng nhé ạ
ừ ừ
à à
Em tải phần mềm gì à Ok đây để mình nói
qua với các phần mềm
ẩm thực tế là các bạn nào có nhiều bạn
nếu mà thực ra theo theo mình dậy thì
mình sẽ dạy equal sau đó thì đến TP Và
thậm chí âm một chút HTML cơ bản để mà
hiển thị ra cảnh trước T nữa thì các bạn
nếu mà vội pp thì các bạn sẽ phải học về
máy cao hơn là SQL Server mình nó dậy
nhưng mà thử cá hai thằng này nó nó rất
tương đồng nhau Nó lại bia mà bạn sẽ
thấy nó rất tương đồng nhau về sau mình
sẽ chỉ dạy lại một chút cái sự khác nhau
của nó thôi Thế nên là nếu mà các bạn
mày theo cái từ đầu đến cuối với mình ý
thì các bạn sẽ cài một là cài shopee cho
nó dễ này hai cái la do này hai cái này
để mà để mà có sẵn đây mình nó cả là do
này nó sẽ có có sẵn cài SQL để mở các
bạn thì chạy được câu lệnh I
Anh và cha cái này chai cái này trên
mạng bây giờ đến lúc các bạn cũng phải
học cách cha hướng dẫn cài đặt thường
nách và cài đặt được xong rồi Nhờ các
bạn chạy thế nào thì các bạn phải chịu
khó chạm tí ở trên mạng Youtube có nhiều
lắm đều không nếu mà các bạn cài mà bị
lỗi thôi thì các bạn thấy inbox hỏi mình
còn bạn mà bây giờ inbox hỏi mình cách
để nó chạy thì mình sẽ gửi các bạn lên
Google
Và nếu mà bạn mà theo hướng ở bên Java
giống như nhiều bạn theo hướng ở bên áp
hay ra và ấy thì các bạn có thể dùng
Chính cái ép keo này của mình không lại
FTP server
chính xác nào nó là đầy đủ là Microsoft
Word mình đúng
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi mình trả lời được các bạn rồi
đấy đúng không
A
nagging thì mình thấy tiện hơn từ khi
mình sang nó con mình không dùng shopee
nữa nhưng mà chính vì Dragon nó có kiểu
tích hợp rất nhiều cái nó kiểu nó đau
não ấy xin Thế là cậu nhiều nơi sẽ dùng
shopee cho nó nhanh cài nó dễ hơn cảm
thấy
A và đúng nhầm như có bạn hỏi đấy Thì
lúc đầu mình cũng chia sẻ các bạn nếu mà
các bạn kiểu khoa học khoa cái này cho
biết đã chứ còn cái gì vội thì các bạn
tra SV Online này rồi các bạn lên chính
trang này không các bạn ấn vào mới fqr
này sau các bạn chỉ việc Copy lại những
cái lệnh kiểu gõ lại những cái lệnh này
thôi Rồi các bạn chạy ở được thế này thì
như là không cần phải class đã ta bây
giờ đã yêu ra đây luôn nhá bạn sẽ chỉ
cần chạy mấy cái clip table nha Đây mình
sẽ thử các bạn xem này lại trang này
đúng không xong rồi lại Loan tiếp này à
à à
thế này và cuối cùng gian tiếp ghé thăm
em
khi bôi đen nó ra nóng không
em hết
I Connect cả đồng hồ click to Connect a
thì nó phải định cảnh báo mổ khác
ở giao diện không thân thiện
A5 này vào cung và rắn
ở đó có sẽ thời gian đúng không đánh các
bạn sẽ dùng kẹp mi online nhé được nếu
các bạn chưa cần ca gì cả
dù tổng kết lại tổng kết lại thì mình
nghĩ là mình các bạn hãy xem lại video
hơn là tổng kết lại
anh đúng không
ừ ừ
I like nước thì cài cái gì à tao Ngon
thì nhiều có lại cho linus
mà thực ra là dao con mình nhớ là thích
hợp với cái này nó nhanh hơn rất nhiều
mà
Ừ thôi không tổng kết lại rồi nha các
bạn hoàn toàn Xem xem lại cái video này
được mà đúng không Mình sẽ không thể kết
bài tập là gì á bài tập đây mình sẽ có
linh này nhá bạn thì mình sẽ gửi các bạn
Linh chưa Nói chung là tí Mình sẽ gửi
các bạn hãy link các bạn yên tâm
Đúng rồi có bạn hỏi sếp sao gì á ok
À mình quên quên cái đấy Mình quên thật
à
ở đầu tiên là snack sao này bản chất là
nó là kiểu ở các bạn đỡ phải ghi lại tên
tất cả các cụt
Anh ở trong cái bảng này là sự mình muốn
chỉ là tên sinh viên rồi chẳng hạn mình
sẽ sẽ lấy kiểu nghe nó nhanh còn
nếu ở mình muốn lấy tất cả các cột thì
mẹ mất công phải lý lại tất cả cột như
này thì không ổn Đấy do các bạn sẽ dùng
Selection
Tại nó sẽ nở ngắm gì chưa
xe tải
à à
nghe lời chúc Tuấn là gì À cái cái cái
này thì mình từng nói trong vừa nãy rồi
trả các bạn xem lại nhé
ừ ừ
à à ế vé code vip code của chạy được ra
Bắc Bình
anh em cái này thì cho mình không nhớ
lắm được mình không dùng Cái đấy em
a e kia cho data analyst thì như thế nào
mình thì không bên ngành đấy Mình chắc
là trái chỉ gợi ý các bạn các từ khóa để
các bạn học và chưa sâu rồi nó để lại
treo được này thôi mình không đi theo
bên đấy Nên là chắc mình không Cái cái
đôi ta bên này mình tìm hiểu sâu về nó
giống như anh nhiều người bên bác em
thực ra không so với nỗi là kiểu Tìm
hiểu về dịch cơ thể các thứ từ đâu
Chính Anh Tuấn ngồi cạnh mình ở đây mình
tự tin là em yêu mình hơn anh ơi
với các bạn đấy Mà chuyện này bắt lên
đấy các bạn chỉ cần chuyên rồi music
không cần và một tí thuật toán nữa thì
ngon quá các bạn không cần phải chuyên
hạn thẻ Apple lắm khi Apple Nokia để cho
người khác làm nhưng mà Bởi vì mình thấy
học cá học Wow này về sau mình sẽ dạy
các cán bộ của Apple mở rộng chuyên sâu
hơn tí các bạn sẽ thấy đấy tâm huyết
mình tìm hiểu cái đấy nó khá nhiều nha
và biết đâu là các bạn sẽ thấy nó cũng
hay tương tự Giống như mình ý
tự học Excel để làm những người gì mà T
một câu hỏi rất hay này
hồi trước mình từng kể cho sinh viên của
mình về việc là đây thực tế bình để bây
giờ bạn đúng nhá Thử hỏi các bạn nhé À
để xây một ngôi nhà không xây một ngôi
nhà
thì sẽ có phiên trước sư đấy
nhà thầu ở đó ngon và thợ xây
và còn thêm gì nhé nhỉ
anh
nói chua cực đại loại nó như thế này
thật Thực ra còn thêm vài cái tố nữa ra
sự là con
con người kiểm tra có thừa mình không
bền chuyên bên thợ xây trên hệ xây dựng
nên không phải gọi không nắm rõ cái này
lắm Nếu mà mình sử giải thích cái này
theo góc độ của bên lập trình viên bên
dân
dân công nghệ thông tin đi để kiến trúc
sư này thì nó sẽ là kiểu à akitech Đúng
không Nó dịch ra thì sư phải không thì
nó sẽ thường này liên quan đến việc là à
em là người
là người làm đã có bên đấy
nó là mình nhớ tiếng Anh của nó là ta ta
bay À akitech thì phải ra cả bầy a
thì tại sao nhảy sang phụ hồ ở đây rồi
achitect thích như nào đó anh quên tự
như em đang nháo em quên hết từ
được có
đây cha chánh sẽ không nhớ gì cả
để ngoài akitech ngon không nhớ cha
cái
nhà thầu nhà thầu thì nên phù hợp với gì
anh nhỉ
Em không nhớ thì ra đấy là đấy là một
trong những cái cơ bản nhất của bên IV
các bạn đừng cười nó là một trong những
kiến thức cơ bản nhất của IP đó là Thậm
chí còn sai chính tả tra Google nó tự
động sửa các bạn đấy đấy đấy một cái hay
đấy là trong IP có rất nhiều thử các bạn
chỉ cần nhớ từ khóa thì tra chứ các bạn
không cần phải nhiều Chính xác cái từ
đấy là là kiểu nó phải như thế nào đây
đây những cái mà mình chào Google liên
tục hàng ngày luôn thường xuyên luôn mà
toàn là những cái mà kiểu nó dỡ các bạn
bởi vì mình có ai phạt mình khi mình tra
Google đúng không ạ Alo alo hiệu trưởng
đang giờ đến anh em không cười nha
Nhưng mà hiệu trưởng và nó cười của mày
à
Ừ đúng rồi kỹ năng Google là chị năng
quan trọng nhất đấy thế nên là mình sẽ
thể hiện và các bạn đã việc là không
phải là mình à Cái này đúng nhận mình
quên thật nhưng mà đã nói là không phải
là nhiều khi mình sẽ cố tình sao gỗ để
các bạn thấy là và một kẻ người
mình thì được tính cho sooyeon mình
không đến nỗi junyo xin em nhé
nhân viết ngay Vậy còn chuno là kẹo tập
sự kiểu mới mới vào ấy siro là bạn đã có
235 thí nghiệm ấy thì thì mình sẽ vẫn sẽ
trao Google thật chị trừ khi mình mà lên
thì cái tầm mà không phải cho gồ nữa thì
chắc là mình thằng nó viết ra cái viết
ra những cái đoạn đấy mình cũng phải tra
nữa chứ
à à
Ừ đúng rồi dần này thì toàn copy paste
nhưng quan trọng mình phải biết copy
mình phải biết sao Google chọn này copy
chọn
đúng không ạ
ở Serie A
Anh siêu siêu mình biết xanh Đạt
à à
có kỹ năng chào Google tí nào cho gỗ
mình là
Ừ từ khóa từ khóa là chủ yếu mình hạn
chế mấy cái từ cậu How to hay các thứ
thứ bây giờ
ạ bây giờ xử đi
à À đúng rồi đúng rồi mình Mình quên về
cái vụ nói cả về vụ à
hai triệu y này có một chuyện hay vì
kiểu này nhé
ở đó là các bạn Trà sự muốn tra về kiểu
độ lớn tối đa ở tuổi này chẳng hạn thì
xa Limit này nên cha bằng tiếng Anh nên
trang một từ khóa tiếng Anh thôi mình
không lên
tra bằng tiếng Việt cũng như là kiểu
phải đi đầy đủ là How big
in its hay có thứ mình tra chị ngắn gọn
ngay độ lớn đúng không và giới hạn nó
xong như thế này
có một cái cái vui về cái cái này
đó đó đó là các bạn biết à video Gangnam
Style không nhỉ cho các bạn biết qua về
Gangnam Style đúng không Đấy và các bạn
bao giờ nghe qua về cái vụ Gangnam Style
Gangnam Style là cái video đầu tiên vượt
ngưỡng 1 tỷ lượt xem trên YouTube đấy
đúng không ạ
Khi một vật không không Em đang nói là
đầu tiên rồi công tỉ đấy thì sau đó thì
về sau nó vượt cái ngưỡng cả cái bộ số
đếm vừa rồi mình cho bạn xem nó là 2 tỷ
như này là đúng không Và nó khiến cho
cái bộ đếm của thằng YouTube trở về âm
các bạn nghe cái bộ này chưa
cho mình
À em tưởng xanh em ạ Luôn số đến YouTube
mọi người bảo em đang đi xa đơn
Không không cái này nó là liên quan đến
chính cái kiến thức học đấy đúng không
Đây nó liên quan đến chính kiến thức học
đấy vượt bộ số đếm của YouTube này đúng
không Thì cái này liên quan đến việc là
mình lưu lại kiểu thế thì bản chất nó là
số nguyên nhưng nó chỉ có giới hạn từ âm
2 tỷ cho đến Dương 2 tỷ thôi đấy thế nên
là
ba lần đấy là vượt cái số đếm làm cho nó
quay trở lại ngâm 2 tỷ nhá thì mình sẽ
phải mình sẽ phải tăng cái giới hạn lên
nó vẫn là kiểu in thì có bạn sẽ biết
thêm những khái niệm mà thực ra kiểu
cùng là kiểu y như các bạn sẽ thêm long
in là sẽ nặn hay là medium thì phải và
Shop Hack time in nhớ rồi nữa rồi fine
em ạ để làm giảm cân bộ nhớ đếm bộ nhớ
của nó đây nó sẽ chiếm ít bộ nhớ hơn các
thứ thứ họ chiếm nhiều bộ nhớ hơn thứ
à à
chị đánh cái này là đấy và các bạn thấy
vừa rồi đã chị thế này làm một cái
không không lạc đề đâu
à lạc đề là cái vụ mà hồi nãy các bạn
đang nói về kiến trúc sư đúng không ạ Nó
phải hp
xin lỗi xin lỗi Ok cái kiến trúc sư vừa
nãy đang nói rồi Anh Kiến Trúc Sư là các
bạn sẽ được lương cao nhất nếu mà trong
cái danh sách vừa rồi thì ý mình ở thế
thì rước sư sẽ lương cao nhất và nó là
liên quan hệ pháp đã ta bây akitech chưa
Tao Bac si Taxi đưa mà sẽ thăm nhất bởi
sao Bởi vì cả người mà chuyên sâu về bên
TB mình vừa phải tính Xem vẽ cái nền
móng sao cho mà để mà mình xây được ngôi
nhà mà về sau mình ít phải sửa ngôi nhà
đáng nhất
ờ ờ
anh Bởi vì biết ở giá sự khách hàng nó
sẽ không được xoài thường k01 khách hàng
nằm ở kiểu đề các bạn xây xong thì xây
xong cái sản phẩm mà các bạn không phải
sửa cái gì chắc chắn các bạn sẽ phải sửa
các bạn sẽ phải nâng cấp nó lên đúng
không Bây giờ Giả sử một bài toán
ạ bây giờ Giả sử có một bài toán là tự
nhiên bạn sẽ ngôi nhà 5 tầng rồi tự
nhiên Khách hàng đòi thêm một cái phòng
ở tầng hai đấy ạ Các bạn làm như nào
đúng không Thì bạn không tình những cái
trường hợp mà có thể xảy ra đấy thì phải
đập cả ngôi nhà đi làm lại đúng không
thế thế nên là
cái người mà vẽ ra cái ngôi nhà đấy
người phải tính toán rất là cẩn thận
cũng như ạ
và học kia này có thể là
là người viết là những cái cậu Ừ cái tối
ưu các thứ thứ của cái ngôi nhà lấy nữa
Thế nên là kế nhàng axwell này cả chuyên
sâu các bạn sẽ cảm thấy hay và thực ra
là thu nhập rất là khá thu nhập cao nhất
trong tất cả mày cái danh sách mình vừa
nói ừ
Ừ
bắt đầu hơi lan man quá đúng không nói
chắc là mình hơi bị dài dòng quá rồi cho
mình tạm kết thúc ở đây nữa bạn nào
không thắc mắc thêm nhé em
Ừ đúng rồi lương nó không chắc chắn nó
nhìn đâu rồi đường Lương của lập trình
viên đã tầm Mã 500 đô cho đến hơn vài
nghìn đô nhưng mà lương của bắt đầu
lương cực gọi là
phụ nữ khởi đầu của database
architecture Lương nó phải hơn 5000 đô
đổ lên
Nói thế cho các bạn Cảm thấy có động lực
thôi tạm dừng buổi hôm nay Cảm ơn các
bạn